black and white looks cooler when i post
something in color
it's just because that picture i don't
think looks appropriate or looks the way
i want it to look or looks the way i see
it because i think i kind of see things
in black and white too
you know as far as like something being
part of my brand i don't think about
that i don't i don't not a brand you
know i'm just a person
well so i don't like trying
managed
[Music]
you know that's just not
i just like simple imagery
i like things black and white i like it
to be dark that's the way the world
looks to me
and so that's what i post that's just
how i am i guess
i mean it yeah it never seemed
intentional but
the fact is it is part of your brand and
brand has become like a bunch of things
now you know what they say personal
brand your personal brand is a thing
even if you don't have a business
apparently
from what i understand
so you're applying something on me yes
okay well that's just hey it doesn't
make a lot of sense you live in society
uh okay i guess where i disagree with
you
is i would consider i had a brand if i
had a team of people that were sitting
around saying what would we like to
convey about your about what are you
trying what's your messaging hey well i
think black and white really conveys
that kind of edgy but still tough
image that you're going through oh yeah
that's great that's exactly what i want
to portray people no that's not
happening yeah i like black and white
pictures dude well [ __ ] looks cooler
when it's black and white there's a
black and white picture yeah
i dig it and i dig your assessment of it
and i understand or whatever but the
fact is
in the field
that's kind of how it works like it's
like you can't really escape it sure
you're not pursuing a very specific
image of your personal brand maybe
that's just who i am right exactly right
but after you that's what they say and
here's the thing i didn't make up these
rules i i'm just over here reporting
from what i understand it's insane where
even if you didn't even have social
media that would be part of your brand
what would be part of my brand oh social
media this part of the brand
okay your personal brand it's true but
you guys what what if i woke up in the
morning and ate frosted flakes every day
that would be part of my brand yeah i
really like flower flakes so i woke up
every day and i hate them yeah that's
part of your brand yep and how's this
this is how deep it can go
let's say you never ate frosted flakes
ever in your life but one day you did
the fact that you never do and then one
day did that's part of your brand so
what you're saying is this brand is your
life yes okay whatever that's what
you're trying to do whatever you're
putting forward but what i'm saying is i
don't believe you i don't think you're
right i think there's a difference
between a person yeah and a brand yes
and i think a person which is what i am
i like certain things yeah i like steak
is that part of my brand no that's part
of the brand of someone that's trying to
sound cool because they oh i'm i steak
cause i'm a red meat guy or whatever i'm
not saying that i like steak why do i
like steak cause i like it
not so i can sell it not so not so i can
uh uh make it
who i am cause i think it reflects being
tough no i like steak because i like it
i brush my teeth every day why do i do
that because i i like to have a good
dental hygiene i want to have teeth when
i get older so i can eat more steak yes
does that make me a dental hygienist no
so i'm just a person yes and you're
trying to make me into
a brand and it doesn't make any sense
technically i'm not trying to make
anybody do anything look i'm like again
i'm reporting from the field you know
these are the this is the new craigslist
what if you just said
so you're saying that brand and
personality are kind of co-mingled now
from a perspective of
social media not depends on what you
mean by commingled so personality is
part of your personal brand
yes okay what you wear is part of your
personal brand if you wear cologne
it's part of your personal brand if you
don't wear cologne and that's part of
your personal brand if you don't wear
deodorant that's part of your personal
brand i'm saying everything
yes sir
everything you do or don't do and
especially if it's consistent that's
part of your quote-unquote personal
brand apparently okay hey look
it just because you have a personal
brand doesn't mean you're pursuing the
development of your personal brand okay
for the brand's sake which is what i
think you okay hey this is a new thing
for me too understand i understand your
uh reluctance to accept you know the
reality of your whole personal brand oh
you say all right black and white
in as far as branding goes called noir
as far as anything goes really black and
white no are so it's like jocko noir
that's your brand that's your personal
brand jaco noir
okay bro
bro i'm helping this guy in his in his
asu college class brown yeah
but um
to answer his question and not go off on
some random tangents it's not right any
sense it's not random
let me tell you um to answer your
question
do i do i do this intentionally nope
why do i post it in black and white
because i think it looks cool
and
is this part of my brand nope that's
just who i am so i i'm answering your
questions you can accept my answer
you're gonna accept echo's answer that
all that stuff is my big all right i
don't accept that last answer the no
answer is that yes that's my uh opinion
okay regardless of your feelings of it i
can see that your brand is to be
argumentative over dumb [ __ ] so i'll let
you maintain that okay
okay all right it's dumb now okay all
right i didn't say this though i don't
make that
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] okay yeah it is dumb but
i don't make the rules over here i'm
just hey i'm the messenger over here
[Music]
how about this i'm gonna move on to the
next question in a serious note i've
gotten to ask questions you know like in
official scenarios about you know
john can you talk to us about how you've
developed your personal brand and i'm
always like i always give them the same
answer like hey this is just who i am i
really don't there's nothing i do right
i don't think about it yeah
i like black and white pictures oh cool
yeah i like to work out cool
yeah and i you know why and i here's the
thing i understand that's why to be
honest it's very fun to talk to you
about it because you're so resistant to
it i i feel you man because it's like
bro i'm not trying to develop especially
someone like you well that's yes okay
now now you're starting to talk uh make
some sense yeah if you're like hey you
know what i'm gonna post this picture
from this angle because the sun's coming
over here and due to my personal brand i
don't post junk pictures and i'm gonna
put this filter on it to make my
whatever like contrast better like this
is all part of the game right if you're
working hard to develop your personal
brand in those ways or whatever to some
i don't even i don't think that's true i
think that yeah that's what people are
doing and it's part of this whole
ecosystem that's part of the game i
think
i'm not for or against it you know it
just depends on the circumstances but
someone like you from what i understand
i can't read your mind i'm not a minor
eater
but
for someone like you it seems like that
wouldn't really make much sense that's
not part of my brand it's not part of
your dad
having a brand being a brand is not part
of my brand yeah there you go just like
you're probably not gonna get
a manicure and pedicure on any regular
basis either you are correct yes so
never had either one of those exactly
right but a lot of fingernail stuff
right
toenail stuff yeah
exactly right so and a lot of people do
that guys and girls
yeah oh freaking yes a lot
quote a lot depends on what you've been
buying i've never known anyone that's
had that except for maybe like
my wife
yeah now that you mentioned my wife's
ever done that okay i can't say never
but maybe well she of course she might
uh then again i don't know
i don't know i don't know either so i
haven't talked to her about that ever so
i wouldn't know but i do know a lot of
people
who normally get manicures and pedicures
yes okay
now you will not you're part of my
personal brand i'm not doing it exactly
right and
developing this conversation
these are important things these are
important things to know i think i think
i don't know
but even so just like you don't pursue
manicures and pedicures because it's
like bro i have fingernails i don't need
to shine them and do all this stuff or
whatever that you regard developing
actively developing in detail your
personal brand the same way see
that's how i see it
next question next question for the love
of god what's your recommendation for
handling
you